I do want to talk before we move on about
just the sort of addendum story to the entire,
uh, Ukraine impeachment fiasco, Joe Biden
scandal.
This is sort of an ancillary story, but it
is part of the continuing comedy of errors
that the white, uh, that the Trump white house
continues to be the Trump white house accidentally
set their talking points on the Ukraine fiasco
directly to house Democrats and Nancy Pelosi.
And every time that I see a new headline about
the entire Ukraine fiasco, I think this one
has to be wrong.
This one must be from a satirical news website
or something, but the headlines are real.
There were talking points that the Republicans
put together the Trump white house and with
Republicans put together to fight against
house Democrats who of course have essentially
launched an impeachment inquiry against Donald
Trump.
And they put those documents together, they
put those talking points together and then
they send them directly to Democrats.
And this is the funniest thing, but after
we do this, I want to talk about the content
of the talking points themselves.
So they send out, uh, the, the talking points
and it contains a defense of the phone call
between Trump and the Ukrainian president.
Why?
It was all great, how the real scandal is
the leak, about the content of the phone call,
not the content of the phone call itself.
And then shortly thereafter, the white house
realizing its mistake, tries to recall the
message through their email system, which
of course it was too late to do as the ship
had sailed.
And the talking points had been published
or work to be published soon thereafter.
So more in competence at the Trump white house.
But the content of the talking points is actually
the most important thing here.
You can tell how weak the hand of Republicans
is by their talking points.
For example, their defense of the allegation
that there is a quid pro quo between Donald
Trump's military aid and Ukraine smearing
Biden.
Their talking point is that the aid package
wasn't specifically mentioned in the call.
And as we've since found out, the phone call
had as a precondition this desire to talk
about Joe Biden and the investigation and
the eventual smear that they hope it would
come.
Anyone who knows anything about politics knows
that this is not how things work.
Trump doesn't personally on the same call,
uh, ask for an investigation into Biden and
say, until you do it, I'm not giving you the
money.
This is not how politics works.
This is not how quid pro quo works.
This is not how ultimatums work and holding
hostage of military aid.
And of course we've since found out that there
was already a discussion in advance and Rudy
Giuliani was involved and other people were
involved in setting the preconditions for
this phone call between Trump and the Ukrainian
president to even take place.
These talking points that they sent out as
boneheaded as it is to send it directly to
Democrats are talking points that would only
even possibly work on the most naive and uninformed
follower of politics.
You can tell how weak their talking points
are because they mentioned the deep state
in their talking points.
They say as a suggested talking point that
this case just shows another example of the
deep state, the media and Democrats in Congress
damaging our national security.
They're suggesting that Republicans defend
Trump.
This is a talking point.
They workshopped presumably suggesting that
we defend that they defend Donald Trump by
blaming the deep state.
You know, your talking points are really weak
when you have to raise the deep state conspiracy
to show that everything Donald Trump did is
okay.
And then of course, Jay, maybe just as importantly
in all of this is that we've since learned,
uh, the full scope of the coverup attempt
that existed.
Donald Trump ultimately releasing what was
initially called the transcript later actually
said, well this is actually a memo.
And really what it was is an extraordinarily
um, a, a some small percentage, uh, piece
of the transcript.
And we know that when you have a 30 minute
phone call and you put out a four page double-spaced
memo, you are cutting out a whole bunch of
stuff.
They made the calculation that that was actually
going to paint the conversation in a better
light than what the full transcript would
do, which should make us question what is
in the actual full transcript here.
Every single element of this is a combination
of complete and utter incompetence like sending
your talking points to house Democrats and
the obviously shortsighted decisions that
are being made haphazardly.
This will help us more than that other thing
happening, not even realizing that they are
actually being further damaged even by, for
example, the partial transcript or memorandum
that they put out.
So look at what has developed in the last
72 hours and then think for a second what
is going to happen in the next 72 my prediction
for the next 72 hours is more details about
whistleblower number two, which involves the
IRS.
I'm guessing by Monday we will know a lot
more about that.
I predict another one of these completely
erratic unhinged tweet storms over the weekend
by Donald Trump.
My prediction is that by Monday morning we
will be able to report to you that Donald
Trump has gotten even more involved in everything,
really everything up to and including obstruction
and witness tampering related to this whistle
blower or whistleblower number two, and who
knows what else will have happened over the
weekend, but certainly by Monday I predict
we will have a lot more to report on here
as well as uh, the increased support for the
impeachment of Donald Trump among the American
public.
I already saw one poll about that this morning
and my, my prediction is by Monday we will
have even more.
So I'm glad you're with us today.
We have so much to discuss, so much to talk
about.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
D Pacman.
Make sure you follow the David Pakman show
on Twitter at David Pakman show and of course,
do not miss my Twitch live streams at twitch.tv/david
Pakman.
If you have an Amazon prime subscription,
you can subscribe to me on Twitch prime for
free.
It costs you nothing.
It counts as a paid subscription for us at
twitch.tv/david Pakman.
We will take a very quick break and be back
with so much more including more
impeachment discussion, whistleblower discussion,
2020 discussion, so much more.